it is chris trevka here with his coach
christian carrillo thank you alejandro
yes we are here with a very happy victor
of the round uh chris
four out of four such a dominant display
in the first part of this event how does
that feel yeah yeah i don't know what's
going on i didn't expect this even today
um
i i really don't know how to describe
what i'm feeling right now it's one of
the best moments of my career well i'm
going to quiz you do you know who else
started this tournament with five out of
five three years ago
um
no idea your coach i did oh really i
started with five out of five so that's
your uh quest for tomorrow uh chris take
us through the game
all right
i even forgot right now what the opening
was
okay french
so now i can
my coach christian is always telling me
that i shouldn't play french so i'm
really really happy
that i want this one
this is a tricky line this is uh this is
new and
i feel like there's a lot of options for
both sides
and i
am i was really happy because i picked
the option that i think my opponent
wasn't prepared for because
after h5 the typical response is h6
but i knew that knight f5 is also one of
the options
but everyone usually plays h6
so i chose to play knight f5 i was
hoping i would get him out of prep and i
think i did because he was thinking here
for 10 minutes he played the right move
bishop f5 is a good move but now i think
white is supposed to play h6
um
and after g takes h6 cd4 if i'm not
mistaken
and
it's some kind of a bishop e6 knight c3
game
it's crazy but uh
white is slightly better
but i was i thought that it looks visib
it looks like black is better in the
position because i have the g file i
have the attack and if he doesn't know
the line then for sure he's not gonna go
for it because i wouldn't go for it with
white and that's exactly what happened
it's a good logic
so he took on f5 he did not play the
move h6 he played
knight to c3
and uh i feel like
this bishop to g5 was a very crafty move
were you surprised by his response f4 i
was because i think i was looking at it
and you know 91 92 usually those are the
types of moves that lose you the game
but not in the french in french they
often win white the games straight out
of the opening so i was a bit worried i
knew that i'm probably objectively fine
after castling but i was really worried
uh
about rook g3 and g3 was giving uh quite
the advantage after bishop g5 or before
now in this one now so i was worried and
i knew that bishop g5 is probably not
the best but i really didn't want to be
under such an attack even even if this
is objectively good for black i
don't like it because h6 is hanging and
that's why i played bishop g5 and i was
very happy i didn't play rook g3 because
i felt like that's a
that's a good move
my idea was to play bishop c1 and rook
c1 and castle and even though i'm
strategically worse here than i was
before i felt like he will at least not
mate me and it's a game
um
queen d2 maybe and
maybe i have to play something like king
h8
but i thought that this is okay still a
very long game
i thought that i'm okay but
maybe i'm not maybe white is just better
i don't know
all right but f4 happened and
where did the big mistake from him come
i think f4 was a big mistake because now
he has no attack and uh his position
doesn't make sense his last couple of
moves 9192 don't make sense
in this setup
i agree with that
and after that it felt like a slow build
up for you to just uh optimize your
pieces
and he was really looking for that
breakthrough which never came well it
came but unfortunately at great uh cost
i think he was supposed to play knight
g3 instead of g4 and i think the
position is very interesting maybe queen
a6 is a small mistake
um
now f5 is hanging but
even if he takes on f5 i usually have a
counter play with queen f1 what was your
move what was your prepared move at this
point after knight gt i actually wasn't
so sure so i always have the option to
play g6 but that looks terrible so
i was thinking about bishop f8 but that
might be losing
i don't know knight f5 queen f1 i was
i was going to calculate this
i didn't know what's going on
i mean i'm certainly not losing my
pieces are active and doesn't seem like
i'm getting made it
but interesting sacrifice
and he decided to go g4 were you
surprised by this movie very surprised i
think uh i'm a bit fortunate in the last
few rounds that it seems like my
opponents are really trying to beat me
even when they could play without like
this is a very risky move
my opponents are always choosing to play
these risky variations
and i definitely felt like g4 shouldn't
be possible his pieces are on e1 and e2
and his bishop on c3 is not doing much
so i didn't really
think that g4 could work
and indeed it didn't it felt that the
build up actually only helped the black
especially after he gave up the bishop
on c3 and then you just kind of cleanly
cruise to victory of course this seems
already quite hopeless for your opponent
chris congratulations a dominant victory
a dominant display up to this point well
good luck in the rest of your games
thank you